(boxing bell rings and trumpet sounding)
- Manny Pacquiao and Floyd Mayweather
could punch over 50 times in 10 seconds
based on light training footage.
Do you think you can punch more than that?
- I'm not sure, I could try.
- I think she can.
- I think I would do really bad.
- How many punches do you think
you could throw in 10 seconds?
- About 10.
- 10?
That's like 40 less.
- Like 12?
- 12?
- I think 1000 might be
too high of a number.
- But I am from Grand
Rapids like Floyd, so...
We'll see, we'll see.
- Home town advantage, maybe?
- Yeah, maybe.
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one. Go.
- One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
- Four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
- One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
(counting rapidly)
- [Voiceover] Stop.
- 41. I counted 41.
I counted 43.
48.
46.
45.
- Alright, 51.
- 54.
(boxing bell rings)
- Kinda surprised, a little winded,
but I'm kinda surprised.
- So how do you think you did, champ?
- I think I probably
did good than I thought.
- I heard the little girl did 41.
You know what I mean? You
always like to make sure
that you're kinda like in the
same range as your opponents.
- That's a little girl.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
I mean a fight is a fight
is a fight is a fight.
- If I was getting paid as much as...
What's his name? Pacquiao?
- And Floyd Mayweather.
- Yeah, I probably would do a lot better.
- Were you guys surprised
at his performance?
- I was surprised.
- Thanks. Thanks fellas.
- A lot of support from your friends.
- Who do you guys got in the fight?
Do you know who Mayweather
and Pacquiao are?
(laughing)
- Tell him Floyd Mayweather.
- Floyd Maywell.
- Floyd Mayweather.
- Pacquiao.
- Well, I'm gonna go for Floyd.
- I'm gonna go ahead and say
Manny Pacquiao for the win.
- So I'm gonna say Mayweather.
- I'm gonna have to go with Mayweather.
- Mayweather.
(booing)
- You were only nine less than
the heavyweight champs of the world.
How do you feel about that?